Hi, welcome back. In this session, we're
going to start to talk about market
efficiency, why it matters, and how it
might drive your search for or lack of a
search for an investment philosophy. The
question of whether markets are
efficient is central to investing. And
here's why. If markets are in fact
efficient, the market price is the best
estimate of value. And if that is the
case, the way you and I invest will
forever be driven by that by by that
endgame. If markets are not efficient,
the market price can deviate from value.
In which case, the question you're
asking is, can I find a way to exploit
it? And every investment philosophy is
built on the presumption that you can do
that. Market inefficiencies are the
basis for finding cheap or expensive
stocks. And if you believe markets are
inefficient, then you can find that
subset of stocks where you can spend
your time looking for bargains or
looking for overvalued companies. In
effect, what you're trying to do in your
study of market efficiency is not answer
an abstract question, but improve your
odds as an investor because you believe
markets are inefficient and you can take
advantage of that inefficiency.
With all of that said though, it is very
difficult to answer a question which I
think is a basic question that every
investor asks. What is an efficient
market? What does it mean when we say a
market is efficient? It doesn't mean
that the price is always equal to the
value. That's that's a presumption that
some people have. That's not true. In
fact, in an efficient market, prices
will deviate from value pretty much for
every stall. The only basic presumption
that creates efficiency is those
deviations are random. In other words,
you know the price is wrong, but you
don't know in which direction. So
there's an equal chance in an efficient
market that a stock is under or
overvalued and you have no way of
breaking that equality.
If those deviations are not random
though, we open the door. If market
mistakes are systematic and you can use
something to find them, then every
investment philosophy becomes a search
for that factor that will allow you to
find what's undervalued and what's
overvalued.
So with that lead in, let's talk about
the different definitions of market
efficiency. First, if you ask me are
markets efficient, I can't answer the
question. That's too broad a question.
And here's why. Markets are all over.
There are markets and stocks and even
within markets and stocks different
geographies, different exchanges. It is
entirely possible
that some markets are efficient, some
are not. In fact, I can say conclusively
that making the statement that all
markets are efficient is too strong.
That that statement is false. That some
markets are likely to be inefficient
and others can be efficient. You can
have even have markets be efficient for
some investors and not for others. Why?
Because you have differences in taxes
and transactions cost that can cause
those variations. Or a market can be
efficient to some investors some of the
time and not efficient others. Pockets
of inefficiency can open up across
markets and across time. And almost
every definition of market efficiency
has to be tied to what information is
embedded in stock prices. In fact, more
than 50 years ago, Gene Farmer won a
Nobel Prize for drawing a distinction,
not only defining efficient markets, but
drawing a distinction in three
definitions of market efficiency. In
weak form efficiency, basically market
prices reflect all of the information in
past prices.
What does that mean? You can't use past
prices and charts and trends to detect
what's coming next. That's weak form
efficiency. In semi-rong form
efficiency, market prices reflect not
just the information in past prices, but
in public information, financial
statements, historical data on the
company's income statements and balance
sheets.
Public information is reflected in
strong form efficiency. You go even
further. The current price reflects not
just what's in the public domain, but
what individual investors have as
private information. You think, how the
heck will that show up in prices?
because they trade on that information.
Weak form, semi- strong, strong form
efficiency. But the implications of
market efficiency
are significant for any serious
investor. Because if markets are truly
efficient, then so much of what we do in
investing, equity research and
valuation, is pointless. It's a costly
task that provides no net benefits.
Because in an efficient market, you're
never going to systematically find value
for your money.
In fact, in an efficient market, the
best strategy for you is to pick an
index fund in diversify across stocks,
go back to living the rest of your life.
And before you dismiss it, hold on
because later in this class, we're going
to talk about that strategy relative to
active investing.
In fact, in an efficient market, even if
you start to try to trade, that trading
costs you. So strategy of minimizing
trading is going to generate higher
returns. The more active you are, the
lower your returns are going to be in an
efficient market. So it does matter whe
the markets are efficient. What it does
not imply are the following. And I've
heard people use this the definition of
market efficiency. There are people
argue that if stock prices deviate from
true value, that must be in markets are
inefficient. Not true. As I pointed out
earlier, the mistakes just have to be
random. I've heard people say in an
efficient market no investor will beat
the market in any time period. That's
absolutely not true. In fact, in any
time period roughly half of all
investors at least before transactions
cost should beat the market.
But no and in fact even a group of
investors can breed the market in the
long term because if you start with
enough of investors the law the laws of
probability alone will account for a few
investors managing to succeed multiple
years at a time. You can already see why
proving that markets are inefficient
becomes so difficult to do. But in an
efficient market, if you truly live in
one, the expected return on investment
will be a function of what risk you take
on and nothing else. The amount of
activity, the amount of research you do
will have little correlation with your
actual returns.
So what is it that makes markets
efficient? Because they don't magically
become efficient. What is it that makes
markets efficient?
For a market to be efficient, people
have to think it's inefficient. I know
that sounds, you know, within it sounds
contradictory, but it is in fact true
because here's how markets become
efficient. Every time there's an
inefficiency in the market, somebody's
got to be able to find a way to use that
inefficient to make money. So, they
trade on that inefficiency. And there
are other investors who watch them do
this and imitate them. So for markets to
become efficient they need to be greedy
in the best sense of the word. Profit
maximizing investors who look for market
mistakes try to take advantage of them.
95% of them might fail but in the
process of taking advantage of market
mistakes they drive the market out.
So in fact one of the great
contradictions of market efficiency is
if everybody thought markets were
efficient they would not be efficient.
So here are some general propositions
about market efficiency. The first is
you're more likely to find
inefficiencies in markets where it's
difficult to trade. You're more likely
to find inefficiencies in the real
estate market than you are in large
publicly traded stocks. You're more
likely to find inefficiencies in markets
where there are high transactions cost
and it's difficult to get information.
Maybe some emerging markets as opposed
to developed markets. You're more more
likely to find inefficiencies if
information is difficult to get to, if
it's opaque. And finally, you're more
likely to find inefficiencies if the way
you exploit it cannot be replicated by
other investors. You can't watch what
people are doing and follow them.
Already you can see why some markets
will be more efficient than others. It's
going to be a function of the ease of
trading, transaction scores, how easily
you can get information, how easily you
can watch other people trade and back
out from their trading what they're
trying to do.
As I mentioned the earlier
contradiction, it became it became the
basis for one of finance's most famous
papers, though more than 40 years old,
which talked about how
if everybody believed markets were
efficient, you could not have an
efficient market. And here's why. If
everybody believes markets are
efficient, they'll stop looking for
inefficiencies. And if nobody is looking
for inefficiencies, if inefficiencies
pop up, they will stay as
inefficiencies.
So to me, an efficient market is a
process, a self-correcting mechanism.
Markets are efficient, but then they
become inefficient, they get efficient
again in so basically inefficiencies
show up people, but you need people
constantly looking for those
inefficiencies.
Now, of course, one of the things that
behavioral finance has done is held a
mirror up to traditional finance.
Traditional finance was built on the
presumption
that investors were rational. And in a
world full of rational investors,
efficiency is going to become the
endgame because rational investors take
advantage of market mistakes in the
process drive them out. Behavioral
finance laid out a whole set of
challenges to rationality. Things that
people do that are not consistent with
rational investors. And they argue that
those those irrationalities can explain
why you see stock price bubbles, why you
see momentum, things that go against the
grain of an efficient market. In fact,
you could argue that active investing is
about exploiting those behavioral quirks
that lead collections of human beings to
do things that don't make sense. So, you
could argue that behavioral finance has
laid the foundations for active
investing, though active investing
predates behavioral finance, lays the
foundation for why active investing
might provide a payoff. And if you look
at the psychological studies underlying
behavioral finance and the reason I'm
going to emphasize them is every
investment philosophy as I pointed out
very early in this class is built on a
presumption of investors behaving badly.
Irrational investing. Here are some of
the things that might cause investors to
do things that you might be able to
exploit with your active investing
philosophy. The first is human nature to
to look at information relative to
anchors that they have. So for instance,
your anchors are based on what you've
seen historically. So if you
historically have been used to PE ratios
of 15 and stocks are trading at 20 times
earnings,
your anchor tells you stocks are
overpriced.
Histo psychological studies also show
that stories can sometimes run ahead of
the numbers. That the power of the story
such that people fall in love with the
story. They stop asking questions. Often
bubbles are based on big stories where
people stop asking questions.
It is also very clear from psychological
studies of investors that we tend to be
overconfident and that we tend to use
hindsight bias to sometimes do things
that don't make sense.
Lot of herd behavior in investing.
People buy because everybody else is
buying. People sell because everybody
else is selling. And the final factor
that I think drives a lot of investing
inefficiency is an unwillingness to
admit mistakes. People hold on to losers
far too long. Why? Because a very active
selling admits, you know, as an
admission to the world that you screwed
up. And the reason I emphasize these
psychological and I've just put a subset
of the psychological things that can
cause investors to deviate from
efficiency is you are trying to take
advantage of this behavior. And in doing
that though, you've got to recognize
that this behavior is not going to
disappear overnight. That when you go
against the crowd, you're not rewarded
immediately for going against the crowd.
the crowd can keep going for much longer
know leading to the widely cited um you
know Keynesian maxim markets can stay
rational longer than you can stay solve
it so just be because you can observe
something happening in the market and
attribute it to a behavioral quirk
doesn't mean you can make money on it
ultimately though when you look at the
empirical evidence you see it in the
numbers you see a lot of loss aversion
we talked earlier about you
know about about risk and how we deal
with it. A lot of investors, you know,
when when you give them a choice of
profits and loss, the way they deal with
losses cuts against the grain of what
you'd expect them to see. There's what's
called the house money effect. The way
people invest with money that they think
is house money, somebody else's money is
very different than their own, which can
explain professional money manage, can
also explain what people do when they
invest winnings from other stocks. And
there's a break even effect which is
when you lose money you try to make it
back. And sometimes you try to make it
back in ways that make no sense. When
you observe this in gamblers in in in
general where having lost money you
throw money at longer and longer os
hoping to get back to break even and
investors have the same phenomenon.
Ultimately though this session is not
about not talking about the specifics of
market efficiency but talk about why
market efficiency is such a big part of
investing. why we care and the
behavioral forces that can cause markets
to be inefficient because you need
markets to be inefficient
as an active investor to be able to beat
the market to take advantage
inefficiencies. But as you can see,
taking advantage of behavioral
inefficiencies is a lot easier again in
the abstract than it is in practice. So
in summary then the question of whether
markets are efficient or not is central
to investing and too many active
investors are too quick to decide that
markets are inefficient often based on
observations that I don't think quite
make their case. I've heard people say
that markets are inefficient because
they move a lot. That proves absolutely
nothing. The fact that markets are
volatile can mean that the underlying
value is volatile or that there's
trading happening that's causing price
prices to be volatile. But unless you
can make money on that volatility
doesn't prove that markets are
inefficient. I've heard some people
argue that markets are inefficient
because they know other people and
usually they name names that have beaten
the market over long periods. As I as I
argued earlier, that's not entirely
inconsistent with an efficient market
where there are tens of thousands, even
millions of investors trying to beat the
market. I think later in this class when
we talk about index funds, we're going
to set up the case for why it's so
difficult to make the case that markets
are inefficient in a way that you can
take advantage of that inefficiency to
make money. In other words, we might be
able to prove that markets are
inefficient in the sense that prices
don't always equate to value, but it's
much more difficult to argue that
markets are inefficient in a way that
you can make money off that
inefficiency. I hope you found the
session useful and I thank you very much
for listening.